hinter uns liegt wirklich eine
historische woche merkel bei trump und
wir haben natürlich den beginn des
türkisch niederländischen krieges und
das ist nicht übertrieben freunde
schwere diplomatische krise
der türkische aussenminister durfte
nicht in den niederlanden landen
ich glaube sie haben die landebahn mit
wohnwagen glocke kanal noch ich mal
wieder ein wohnwagen wird was glauben
dieser holländer eigentlich wer sie sind
was glauben die erdogan hat ihn kurz
erklärt wir haben keine ahnung von
internationaler politik und diplomatie
sie sind nervös und feige wie sind
nachkommen der nazis wir sind
verschiffen nachkommen der nazis ich
dachte immer die wohnen argentinien ja
stimmt doch der typ ergo faschismus in
rollen wenn überhaupt gibt in holland
flasche
könnte mich reinlegen mache ich oft
andere geschichte
wer erdogan der dreht komplett frei der
mann leidet noch unter nazi tourette wer
hier jetzt hat er sogar kein witz die
türkischen schulbücher und zwar die für
geschichte umschreiben lassen die wurden
geändert heißt es jetzt adolf hitler
wurde in braunau am ijsselmeer geboren
kurz nachdem er von der tulpen akademie
abgelehnt wurde lernte er seine spätere
frau antje braun kennen zusammen mit
ihrem hund blond lebten wir auf dem
obersalzberg und träumten dort vom
tausendjährigen gleich
die holländer wird
[Applaus]